there's there are a lot of american
spies and diplomats and it started
happening in cuba and now it happened
at the white house do you read about
this the hot chick no
[Laughter]
wow
to talk [ __ ] about him see who was loyal
came out well honeydeck sounds like
something i ordered dave's hot chicken
right it's a job nice huh it was like a
1 a.m
chicken what is a honey dick
she's a government spy but she's really
pretty so she would get asked out by
these politicians so she would go on
dates with them
then she'd have a recording trying to
get them to talk [ __ ] about trump
and other people so she would honey dick
politicians like the cia you should do
that [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah but they have
now now that's not what i was talking
about but i like it
but what they have now is they can't
figure out this weird thing where
diplomats and spies especially will be
walking
and all of a sudden they get hit with
something where it's either a sound that
makes them start throwing up
um gives them a brain injury yeah gives
them a brain injury
so these guys and so when the guy pulled
back he was okay and he went back
into the the area he got he got a brain
injury he got
really sick had to go to the hospital
immediately they don't know what it is
and it's affecting specific people in
the government
including now for the first time at the
white house
in the doors of or in behind behind the
gates of the white house
really yeah so they think it's either
some kind of a weapon
that a foreign agent or some foreign
entity is using
either it's sound frequency that's
discombobulating the brain
or something but it's definitely a
weapon they think that they don't know
about
but it's becoming more and more i heard
about this about two years ago in cuba
that's right it was happening it's
called havana syndrome yes yeah but that
didn't know it was infiltrating our
yes now it's here here and it's getting
more prevalent so it's havana syndrome
all these like spies and these guys got
were literally going like this but and
they were like my head
fell to the ground let's go deeper down
the rabbit hole oh damn you guys hear
that do you guys hear the loud booms at
night
why the earthquakes no booms just like
somebody
does anyone hear any booms ever i don't
but i like where you're going
hey well before it was jamie with his
hair and spirit right now
no but do you never hear any booms like
loud mini explosions
okay go when you go home tonight just
see if you listen what area do you live
in i live in ah by the greek
greek theater los feliz yeah maybe i'm
here in downtown
do you think those are gun shots over
there no there's definitely gunshots
but there's also no idea you can look
them up you can look them up i swear
there's boom there's been some weird
what do you think it is i don't know
there was a phenomenon it was like there
was some weird [ __ ] i liked the way you
did it though i like the way you just
said check it out like whenever you do
that somebody you go you ever sleep in
that room
california town puzzles loud boobs
downtown l.a all right
okay i'm not making it up well that's
like yeah that's why eddie yeah i've
never heard any booms lately that was a
us army training thing
that said 2016 though
right there though march 13th that's
where i'm at i'm in that dimension
silver lake that's right i wonder if
it's i wonder if it could be a plane
break like sound barrier
it's just it's like boom boom now last
year well last year i don't know
people [ __ ] around down the rabbit
hole but did you ever hear the fireworks
[ __ ] yeah
they were putting fireworks in
neighborhoods to let people like make
explosions did you hear that
no dude there was there was a guy uh my
old neighborhood that i lived in
he literally would just stand in the
middle of the street yeah just
light off uh firecrackers why just
because he wanted to
it was like it was like m80s exactly
m80s
specifically and he was just walking
into the street but
at night when everybody's like lane oh
oh
uh my neighbor had his son uh has a son
with autism and it was freaking he was
freaking him out
and she was like hey you go talk to him
uh she ran right over to him and he was
cool
he was like oh okay i'll leave i'm sorry
about that that's cool yeah she was like
why would he do it like he's like
watching him suck this was like this is
like when
when the pandemic like first happened
and then uh he was just freaking out
yeah people just freaking out
i don't know if this dude was just
trying to some people but he was doing
it so comfortably
they get off on that like if you did i
ever tell you about my buddy who's a
defense lawyer
and he has a client this this this very
wealthy family their son
has a problem and the son likes starting
fires
who likes to start a fire and then he
dresses up as a fireman
and he waves traffic around the fire
no yes so there's guy not just go be a
fireman yeah
doing it since he was 14 he's now 20.
no he's still doing it was he recently
in time the judge was like you
get that you know my friends my friends
always got it they pay him so much money
that he's a really good defense lawyer
but
the kid is obviously a sociopath how is
no one
like man maybe just whoa he'll be a
firefighter he's like oh
that's a great idea well not you can't
have a firefighter when you're under
starting it when you're did he start
when the palisades
well here's why he keeps him out of jail
he doesn't start um he doesn't start
massive he starts fire specifically like
a mailbox a little bush
oh he's like this and he's got the tough
stuff on and they're like
go go look for colin i'm sure and
they'll does he put him out colin
you want to come with me yo he's like
guys the fire come around this way
please it's a fire and that's
and no one's waiting let's talk about
white privilege that's fire privilege
they're like oh colin started a little
fire like what is
that calling single yeah i would imagine
he's
thinking he's got some issues with my
baby i'll go start this [ __ ] my son's a
good kid he's an arsonist yeah
he's a narcissist but he's a good kid
but no one thinks it's weird that he's
literally the only person standing there
so
one of the one trait of a sociopath
sometimes is people
that like to cause havoc like create
major problems
and then watch it happen so they like to
they like to like uh
set fire to a mailbox and watch all the
mail burn and they watch
and they're like i did that and they're
like hey can i help
suck well sarah serial killers do that
though
if you guys need help seriously well
it's terrible
yeah i'd be the worst movie because you
could tell with me right away you guys
need help
[Laughter]
that's just your one line you're not a
good actor like we know what you are
yeah that's that's a condition that is
i'm fascinated with weird conditions
people like to take breaking the houses
and take shits on the floor and stuff
and leave
left my mark yeah they don't want to
take anything they just do yes it is
yes yes wow people also do that and laid
it on fire
a billion wicked thoughts oh really yeah
it's it's okay i feel like it's happened
once or twice but i don't think it's
like a
like a real problem so so like another
person [ __ ] on the ground
i'll do one better they'll do it when
people are in the house and what they
get off on
they'll either jerk off or they'll take
a poo in the house what they get off on
this i might get caught and i'm doing
something naughty and then they run out
yeah so no i'm sure it happened how do
you know this
i read about in the book a billion
wickets
oh the billion wicket thunderstorms it's
so they they took
so these neuroscientists took all the
data from
from i guess uh pornhub their the mother
thing to see what people actually
look at when nobody else is looking to
see where fetishes are and what they're
about
it's really fascinating and what was it
oh dude you
did so so where is granny porn the most
uh popular
well in kenya and parts of england why
because you're older
older people take care of kids yeah you
know um what is the most what is the
second most popular word
googled in porn sites well it's mommy or
a derivative of that
there's all kinds of weird [ __ ] oh
there's oh you find out what are women
like what what what do women
yeah do we in in romance novels do they
do they ever mention like girth or size
no they mention passion you know there's
all kinds of weird [ __ ]
it's really interesting so you get a
sense of how how our brains work man
they're passionate they're passionate
about that you know the novels they
don't in the on the youtube they're
they're they're [ __ ]
fifty shades are great well get so sized
size is important in the gay community
so look at men
who are googling uh sir it's important
for community yeah i don't want book
your reading but yeah well you don't
know
yeah do you think women are all about
girth no i'm saying it that's not what
they that's not
you're saying they're not science is not
an issue what they what what it is is
passion they'll talk about
the blood pump i'm saying this book was
written by a small white man
by a shortcut
like in all my years of research women
don't care about you
about your big dad they like you like
short guys you know like
all muscles it turns out you don't have
to have money either this is just
in in my room it's just like passion
i found it here's the answer there it is
big dicks are out boys guilds are in in
england
yeah so england's granny wait because
they because
because uh like nannies oh no so [ __ ]
weird kenya
and um and the you said it came
a weird chip